con mayoría absoluta Marc Ángel fue
elegido vicepresidenta del parlamento
europeo el socialista luxemburgués de 59
años sustituye a la griega Eva Kylie en
prisión por el caso catergate el
parlamento europeo espera pasar
rápidamente página al escándalo de
corrupción
es el momento de ser Franco claro y
absolutamente honesto tenemos que
nombrar y avergonzar directamente
necesitamos una verdadera
responsabilidad política para salvar la
democracia probablemente deberíamos
empezar por hacer una cosa muy sencilla
respetarla y limpiar desde el sótano
hasta el desván en nuestras
instituciones y como aún estamos en
enero propongo por lo tanto un buen
propósito para la Unión Europea en 2023
que la ética Prime por fin sobre el
dinero
se espera que la investigación avance
rápidamente el martes el italiano Piero
Antonio panzeri llegó a un acuerdo con
la justicia belga Se comprometió a
contar a los investigadores todo sobre
el funcionamiento del fraude e incluso a
revelar los nombres de quienes aún no
están Implicados En el caso a cambio su
condena se reducirá a un año de prisión
la justicia belga también ha pedido al
parlamento europeo que levante la
inmunidad de otros dos eurodiputados un
belga y un italiano se espera que las
autoridades europeas tomen una decisión
A mediados de febrero